okay remember after the first
presidential debate when Hillary
Clinton's campaign put out this ad which
was just basically quotes verbatim of
Trump from the debate denying having
said a whole bunch of stuff and then
clips of Trump from other moments saying
the stuff he denied saying during the
debate there was no commentary necessary
from Hillary Clinton or a narrator
because it was just Trump verbatim
versus Trump verbatim we now have a
similar fascinating ad in response to
the vice presidential debate there was a
similar dynamic in the vice presidential
debate where Mike Pence when presented
by Tim Kaine with all sorts of just
insane crazy nonsense that Donald Trump
had said over the last several months
Mike Pence opted not to defend the
comments because of course they're
completely indefensible but rather to
deny that most of them were ever things
that Donald Trump said just like after
the first presidential debate the
Hillary Clinton campaign has put
together an ad which requires no
commentary at all it is just pence
verbatim denying that Trump said things
and then audio and video of Trump saying
those exact things I will play a little
bit of it for you right now
[Music]
let's start with not praising Vladimir
Putin is a great leader Donald Trump and
Mike Pence have said he's a great leader
and Donald Trump has Easley hands
Putin's been a very strong leader for
Russia Vladimir Putin has been a
stronger leader in his country than
Barack Obama has been in this country
Donald Trump on the other hand didn't
know that Russia had invaded the Crimea
oh that's nice he's not going to go into
Ukraine you can mark it down you can put
it down you can take it anyway sorry
there isn't it Donald Trump has said it
deportation force they want to go
house-to-house school to school business
to business and kick out 60 million
people and I cannot believe you're going
to have a deportation force Donald Trump
and I would never support legislation
that punished women should the woman be
punished driving abortion it has to be
some form of punishment more nations
should get nuclear weapons don't try to
defend well he never said that wouldn't
you rather in a certain sense have Japan
have nuclear weapons doughty regular up
in Saudi Arabia absolutely Donald Trump
said keep him out if they're Muslim Mike
Pence put a program in place to keep
total and complete shutdown of Muslims
he is asking everybody to vote for
somebody that he cannot defend
[Music]
yeah these ads write themselves by just
being juxtaposed video of pence denying
that Trump said certain things followed
by videos of Donald Trump saying them
aren't they making it too easy Rachel I
mean there is just no ambiguity about
vocabulary or language or anything it's
just what they say during debates and
then what they said outside of the
debates a direct contrast I don't know
exactly how the mind of a trump
supporter operates but this is really
damaging destructive stuff for them
isn't it I mean I'd like to think it's
damaging however there's been a lot of
speculation that the Clinton campaign
actually orchestrated everything so that
they would get a play the tape type of
ad out of this oh yeah so so they were
so devious they set up pence and Trump
to contradict themselves just so they
could make the ad or something like that
right I don't agree with it personally I
had a lot of people believe it however
but the in the CNN poll right afterwards
it said that Mike Pence had actually won
so even by making this do they really
think it's effectively going to change
anything well I think well I mean III
think you're referring to the instapoll
right because then there was a CNN focus
group where they thought that some
people thought pence won but some people
thought Cain won I mean I try not to put
too much stock into those and just wait
for the actual national polling but yeah
I mean on optics there were many people
who felt Trump that that Mike Pence did
well does anybody feel bad for Mike
Pence for having to deal with Trump
saying nonsense 24/7 and then having to
do this horrific damage control I
personally don't some people are
emailing me saying I kind of feel bad
for pence
I don't feel bad for the guy who wants
funerals for miscarried fetuses as a
matter of law in Indiana and chooses to
be Donald Trump's running mate he chose
to be in this position Rachel I say he's
got you know now it's his responsibility
to figure out what what on earth to do I
mean yeah it is his responsibility and I
know we've mentioned this before that he
disagrees with him on a number of things
but he is effectively trying to clean up
what he said by denying it but it's
proven before that this isn't going to
change
any supporters by a large enough margin
yeah there's a small sliver of Trump
supporters who might say oh you know
what this is absolutely insane but
really if it's October if it's
mid-october almost and you're still
weighing your options I don't know that
just some inaccuracies from Pence are
going to sway your vote a very very
disturbing and disappointing that the
obvious lies constant lies aren't having
a bigger impact it really says a lot
about Trump supporters more than
anything else politicians will lie to
the extent that they can get away with
it and with the average Trump supporter
clearly they can get away with it I've
talked about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is Zipcar which gets you
a car when you want it when you need it
they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your zip
card each car share member reduces their
personal co2 emissions by between 1100
and 1600 pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering $25 a free driving
credit if you sign up at join Zipcar
comm slash david support our show reduce
your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join Zipcar
comm slash David